selective equality is so true because we  are only equal until we don't want to be  equal anymore we always want more female  CEOs but nobody wants more female  plumbers you know it's the men who go to  war first it's the men who are building  the very infrastructure which we walk on  you know I was walking on Brickell key  the other day and I saw these men  hanging from these cranes they're  putting these windows on and I saw one  man trying to like hang out the window  to grab the window and it's the men that  are doing that it's not the women men  create the infrastructure that the boss  [ __ ] can then sit out on and go I'm a  boss [ __ ] but who put you there it was  the man the man created the chair the  floor the levels it's the man that's  gonna run into the burning building  you're gonna call the men when somebody  comes and robs your house